[Music]
good evening I'm Shannon Bremen for Bret
Baier
Senate Minority Leader Chuck Schumer
calls it a genuine breakthrough the
White House says it ends crisis to
crisis budgeting a new spending deal in
the Senate would shower both the
Pentagon and domestic programs with
almost 300 billion dollars above
existing limits whether conservatives in
the house will go along with it remains
to be seen
and then there's Nancy Pelosi chief
congressional correspondent Mike Emanuel
is on Capitol Hill tonight to tell us
where things stand good evening Mike
Shanin good evening the drama is
certainly not over even after bipartisan
leaders in the Senate announced
agreement on a two-year budget deal the
compromise we've reached will ensure
that for the first time in years our
armed forces will have more of the
resources they need to keep America safe
the two-year budget deal provides 165
billion dollars more for the military
131 billion dollars more for domestic
programs a debt ceiling increase through
March 2019 disaster relief funding for
hurricane and wildfire victims keeping
the government open through March 23rd
budget deal doesn't have everything
Democrats want it doesn't have
everything Republicans want but it has a
great deal of what the American people
want
after months of legislative log jams
this budget deal is a genuine
breakthrough it does not include
anything for the so-called dreamers
young people brought to this country
illegally by their parents and even
though Democratic Leader Nancy Pelosi
was a part of the negotiations she spent
hours on the House floor demanding a
promise from speaker Ryan on daca the
package really does nothing to advance a
bipartisan legislation to protect
dreamers in the house without a
commitment from Speaker Ryan
comparable to the commitment from leader
McConnell this package it package can I
have my support a spokeswoman for House
Speaker Paul Ryan says he quote has
already repeatedly stated we intended to
a daca and immigration reform bill one
that the president supports at the White
House press secretary Sarah Sanders
agreed immigration should be separate
we've made clear that
budget deals should be a budget deal and
members of Congress like Nancy Pelosi
should not hold our military hostage
over a separate issue we've laid out
what we would like to see in immigration
legislation and I think it's something
that Nancy Pelosi should support and the
Secretary of Defense urged lawmakers to
get it done in a world of wash and
change with increasing threats there is
no room for complacency failure to
implement or fund the 2018 national
defense strategy will leave us with a
force that could dominate the last floor
yet be irrelevant to tomorrow's security
yet the leader the conservative house
freedom caucus says he cannot back the
surge in spending obviously I considered
the president a close personal friend
and and even if he called me and asked
me to vote for this I'm afraid the
answer would still be no at this point I
think it's fiscally irresponsible to
support Republican sources admit
Democrats had some significant leverage
on spending because they need at least
nine Democrats in order to pass a budget
in the Senate meanwhile on the House
floor the marathon speech continues for
Democratic Leader Nancy Pelosi nearly
eight hours old it's being called a
record speech on the House floor
Shannon we'll see how that impacts thing
is Mike Emanuel live for us on the hill
thank you